[Music]
strippers on strike news oh no not the
stripper Union needs a stripper you know
submitted by Greta from the village is
that a reference tonight that was gonna
be Greta from the villa is that a
reference nah you'll find your
references yeah all right New York
strippers are going on strike in a
battle against their bartender support
what is going on why you got a tip
[ __ ] 50% the bar at [ __ ] the bar
Watson get pasta
okay so bartenders these bartenders in
New York they're pretty much shaking
their ass feeling tips off the stage
like swiping the tips wall so they could
keep it on like whatever tips is on the
floor would be the bartenders and the
bartenders don't have to tip the house
and so strippers are like [ __ ] that like
now the strippers our bartenders are
making more than the strippers and they
don't even have to like [ __ ] what the
art they are working for it they're not
getting naked like it also sounds like
these are bartenders that come out with
the drinks - you're right that's why
they have access to the stage know
bartenders a bartender Oh for real did
he stay at the behind the bantha stayed
behind the bar I don't know the
distribution of way but there was this
could be like coyote ugly style
there was this Instagram video that was
posted the caption says oh no I would
end you heel to the face flying on you
like a spider monkey your pigtailed self
would get dragged on stage - I want to
be on it so bad I'll be a great show
don't ever touch the money on stage
you're a bartender so quit shaking your
ass and sell drinks
video from treat tender and then work
okay so I'm gonna show you guys a video
clip period oh damn that's crazy
these two girls are bartenders and the
strippers are up here
yeah yeah she keeps knocking it on the
floor making chains how dare they dance
seductively yeah I keep saying your name
that's true
yelling yeah no you're not the way guy
who with that [ __ ] coffee outfit he
was a security yeah you know I like to
carry what the [ __ ] that's like if I go
to a [ __ ] Justin Bieber concert and
all the backstage freaking stage hands
came out and started dancing I didn't
come for you I can't with Justin Bieber
a lot of strippers are saying like to
see them dance and the money's for them
exactly so then they got the money from
the table and then they put it down on
the bar stage yeah was that what if that
was a safety issue like girl you're
gonna slip on that [ __ ] I don't know
any girl like that I don't know girls
are very like consider it forget their
money they get it no no no but then what
if it was like I'm just gonna so you
don't your high heels don't slip on the
dollar and then she's gonna collect and
be like here I collected this for you
because whatever's on the floors for the
bartenders what yeah so that's why it's
shady or at least in this in this bar
here in their defense the money was
being thrown from in front of the bar
right on the other side she was also
swiping it yeah so because there's
thrown from that direction I imagined
that money maybe was for the bartenders
because it's don't right now you're
making it rain on top of the bartenders
though I'm assuming the bartender
customers when they make it rain they're
just doing their own thing they don't
know where the money's going but that's
not the point the point is is the rules
are staged money is for strippers floor
money's for bartenders
that's just the rules we're looking into
it from a way different perspective true
we got to follow house rules if my [ __ ]
is over here that's my [ __ ] [ __ ] that
it is also means the if you want to make
it rain for the strippers you have to
focus on the trajectory of the
tactically so these people you don't
want to make it go directly down exactly
yeah have you seen those make it rain
guns yeah you spec the dollar yeah they
should just handle though that might not
feel the same though like I know if I
want to make it rain like I like it's my
money I worked for like let me feel it
leaving my hands you know I don't like
doing I like to make it rain backwards
do
[Laughter]
yeah I make it rain would you get the
same satisfaction but it goes right back
to you just like that the rapper cardi B
she kind of time to know I love her and
then I don't love her but I do love know
she used to be a stripper and then she
came on a reality show and that's how
she got her fame oh cool she like she's
also a rapper and now she's huge
but isn't her song the highest like sold
number one on Billboard Lauryn Hill you
do female artists it surpassed like so
many [ __ ] people in sales and it was
a song
there's just insane numbers behind it
and it's a song that's like what her
Instagram videos are so fun Silurian her
before I knew who she was just cuz of
her Instagram saying I think she might
be one of the more most successful I
crossover like on 2 on 3 crossovers from
stripper to reality star reality stars
social media star from social media
start to now a full-on full-blown rapper
Wow how successful I wish I could follow
in those footsteps and she just got
engaged
she's real as [ __ ] so what she said was
strippers are tired of the closet
strippers parenthesis bartenders going
on stage wearing thongs picking up money
off the floor shaking their ass
basically doing everything a stripper
does but loves to scream loud and proud
I ain't no stripper that's what she had
to say about this so they're posers so
they just want to have that kick in
either too anxious I'm still a because I
keep the clothes on there the wannabe
thugs yeah and then the strippers they
have to tip DJ's but the bartenders
don't know so I never know where the DJ
is I just hear his voice [ __ ]
screaming he's always on keeping the
house hype though he's keeping the vibe
up you know and that's why the strippers
to give them to so then now the
strippers they're having a strike
they're saying that were they wearing on
their strike those strippers are crossed
like all of New York or just this bar it
looks like it's New York Oh what the
[ __ ] because all of New York this is
what's happening and so they're saying
that were they gonna play music at the
stripe the strippers does not equal
treatment bartender so like if the
bartender's onthe pay or like make them
pay - yeah yeah yeah has repercussions
for them taking money off the stage
because it's not even their money and
like not have them shake their asses
sure cuz they're not the strippers
they're not there the customers don't go
to see the bartenders the reason why I
thought it was just that bars cuz just
the way the bar said I like the bar and
then the stage it was like thought it
was separate so I'm like why how could
it be all in New York New York because
it's so small cuz they could have like
the bar here in the Japanese yeah cuz if
I was a hot [ __ ] and I was a female
stripper and I saw that [ __ ] happen in
I'd be [ __ ] pissed
iPod jump down the [ __ ] stop on those
no [ __ ] I don't think it's a [ __ ] bet
on it guys coming up dude I'll [ __ ]
kick somebody's fun today
let me hear miss Veronica my voice is
fine [ __ ] it yeah this caption here was
like I end you heel to the face it's
already hard enough being a stripper as
it is and you're not protected by
anything else you don't have a union and
all that stuff you don't have a pimp I'm
all for stripper rights they should
march to Town Hall in their outfits in
their uniform
okay I like calling your mind strippers
are in the stripper clothes 24/7 but
then you did say uniforms yes yes yeah
and there's stripper uniforms just a
bikini right that's what they start off
in that's the normal clothes yeah they
should start off in the stock lingerie
themed
only bikini sometimes it's just body
paint have you guys ever thought about
stripping as a profession I like ice too
yeah that would I don't think I mean I
can't speak like not even not even like
human percent but for example for me I'm
a normal person right one at least one
percent considered being a full-time
drug dealer all the way and also
full-time police officer all the way
even 1% percent I have cuz I remember
when I went I did both I went to a
girlfriends Bachelorette thing and then
we all went and we took her to a female
male like a co-ed stripper solid strip
joint yeah we're like in separate rooms
but you walk in and then they have
and then split off and go yeah and then
it just goes into separate well sounds
amazing
very fresh it was really dope and then I
would watch the girls dancing on my vlog
they're [ __ ] sexy like it was dope
and and I was just like dude I wanted
that skill man like pole dancing and
doing like that's you you need to know
how to be sexy and work with your bottom
like I let me down that's what I was
doing one percent when I saw strippers I
was like for the first time I was like
you're so talented Wow like the way you
spread it just like how do you do so
talented yeah it's amazing I mean I was
like messing around with like a stripper
pole in their house that shit's hard to
get bruises everywhere but for me to
actually be a stripper I think I would
rather be like a cam girl in like
privacy like I just don't want to risk
my life in front of strangers like never
physically beat yeah not physically be
there like I'd rather be behind a camera
doing [ __ ] he's lazy there's the
constant you know what girls it causes
one you're one yes there's physical
danger and you're known locally the
other one is there's no physical danger
but then now you can be at the
supermarket that's her or you could be
at anywhere he could be in Paris that's
her because do it if you're a cam girl
that means you can literally call that
should it be [ __ ] hilarious
like you're just in a supermarket and
the guys with his wife and he's staring
at you like yeah you [ __ ] jacked off
to me you [ __ ] prick [ __ ] yeah I'm
just thinking of it as a comedic sense
bill I think it's hilarious like you had
a supervisor the guys just like this he
knows you but he doesn't know you
because that's the stuff he does in this
like dark web time that was like in the
90s right whenever people would
recognize porn stars before like porn
stars were like really popular or like
you know before they were porn stars
right they're just porn actresses or
yeah just I remember back in the
nineties would be like you can't
actually like say it out loud cuz you're
like
ashamed that you even know who she may
be probably not us but I think I saw it
on sine pill or something the people are
proud of watching for now if you're part
of recognizing people and I can
recognize that person I've seen her
vagina that [ __ ] moles now no were they
mold now they've had it forever I'm so
late on things I'm sorry I don't know I
just found out there's ATM machine hope
you guys enjoyed that episode of JK news
make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]